[Music]
[Laughter]
i don't know what it is
what does that even mean it means
[Laughter]
all right you're gonna you're gonna
really love this uh description so um a
mutant superhuman with crumpled chest no
neck
recessed eyes and nose and airbags in
his lungs has a body that can survive
car crashes they said they call him a
mutant so he looks like the dude from
batman what the [ __ ] he looks like the
dude from oh
was that an arousal though no i just
didn't that's a real person
is that a computer generator like is
that a real person it's a sculpture
but what it is is this it anatomically
shows everything that you would need to
survive a real car crash that arm looks
like bars
this person that is what you would have
to be in order to survive a car crash
without injuries like a no neck man
you'd have to be all of these things so
what are what are those boils on his
chest
you need that those are the air bags to
keep the lungs from collapsing
wait i'm confused is this just just like
an article someone wrote
it's like is this a real person it's
like a science art oh yeah
they were like super human they're like
human if you had a steel chest you could
survive it's to illustrate how fragile
human bodies really are in car crash you
know what's crazy though so in uh when
out my senior year of high school me and
my buddy i lifted so my like neck's
stronger my my buddy doesn't lift at all
yeah we were racing on in montebello
over here and he hit a pocket the car
starts spinning we rear end into a
street light the street light comes and
smashes the car and the car's like
dented in half
both me and him were knocked the [ __ ]
out oh my god immediately i was able to
kind of come to consciousness a little
bit but then i kind of was like going in
and out of consciousness and the
firefighters pulled us out or whatever
and they put us in the ambulance when
we're in the ambulance that's when i
started like waking up and my buddy was
just like
but he wasn't conscious and he just kept
throwing up from all the trauma
when we got to the hospital
or our beds were facing each other and i
could already start to feel like okay
cool i'm kind of like getting back to
normal normal yeah like i can like
someone could ask me questions i can
respond my body was in an insane amount
of pain i'm like i'm really stiff but i
can kind of i'm like i'm there he was
still just throwing up and all that weak
ass [ __ ] and then i was like holy [ __ ]
fascia's weak bro yeah and i was like i
think from the [ __ ] spinning around i
think just having like
more i don't know [ __ ] mass or
whatever it prevented me from having his
injuries and he
left the hospital five days after i left
and even then when he went home he was
still throwing up and he had to lay just
like late i mean this one got brock now
honestly
you kind of look like the rendering he
does
that's bart hey sit like that
dude i'm pretty sure if you have those
like matching shorts i like how he's
wearing like just like jc pen those look
like target shorts like did you just
roll up at target he grabbed a pair of
shorts off the sales rack and he's like
i'm chilling look at his legs yeah he
even has extra joints like on his dude
those are massive
daffodils skip leg day for sure yeah so
it's a collaboration between a team of
doctors artists and car crash
specialists
he kind of looks like kind of looks fine
someone that loves fast food
but also
was born a little deformed it's like in
a ring it looks like an orangutan i
don't think so he doesn't look deformed
to be actually like you know
had sex with a human he looks like a
monkey like he looks like kind of like a
half monkey yeah yeah but he ain't dying
and no buick
roll up i look like you know who he
looks like he looks like ed from um
but also why did they give him no hair
yeah like when they give him like a
stylish haircut that won't get caught in
something like that what do you want to
give him like a fade
or a man but
they didn't have to make them ugly yeah
a little bit of chest hair though
that's fine that's important for the car
crash though a little bit of chest hair
like is this dude fit what's up with the
face all scrunched up why is the face
all scratched so the skull itself has
crumpled zones like the bumper of a car
oh [ __ ]
so it'll just go and it'll probably go
you know what's really important after
the adjuster goes let's see
what would be really really cool if
people just wore their seat belt and so
then we wouldn't have to look like this
that's actually not probably
that's actually not what would you
rather be that dude or just wear a
seatbelt i'd rather die looking
i want to go down like this bro
when ryan drives his head sticks out in
the passenger seat
he still ganks the ride
i never understand people can do that
because i'm a little [ __ ] now with
everything i do
you drive like this now i drive like a
little that's how i drive because i
can't reach the pedal
but i'm far back but i don't sit low i
like being high
and far
but i know people who literally will
drive like this yeah [ __ ]
i'm like where are you this isn't
skeleton sometimes i drive like this
that's integrity no same yeah i mean
it's nice opening up my hips i need to
be close enough to hit the buttons
can i can i ask a cancelable question
yeah let's go my favorite i want to ask
wait she's like
i work in hollywood you know everybody
always said don't text and drive yeah
well then how are you supposed to get
really good at it but also can i say
something can i say something you have
to do it i'm saying about texting and
driving i'm really good at it this is a
hot take do you have your keyboard
memorized on your phone yeah look
texting and driving i do it's not that
hard nope what's wrong no it's just the
tone what's wrong is when people text
and drive they're
85 percent about their phone see
that's so the ratio is right it has to
be the other way you have to forgive the
typos say whatever the [ __ ]
just send a voice note you could do that
too
but i was like you don't have a car from
2000 but but i'll say this
i do but watch tell me something i'll
type without even looking um bart i love
you you're
very handsome go read it out loud please
yeah give him the phone read it read it
okay wait no autocorrect let's see i
think i can do that too
what did it say what is it did he do it
bart i live you oh fair enough gibber
handsome
oh
i love you
but now imagine if it's slightly
peripheral vision
if i'm driving like this like that
slightly but i also i also think add the
red light into the combination if you
can't most people you there's a
prerequisite to be able to text and
drive most people can't even get the
driving right yep so you can't throw in
text messages
if you're a good driver you signal
regularly you know you you look over
your shoulder i got it then hey man it's
the worst thing you've done
while driving hit a cyclist i hit a
cycle
oh i mean like what resulted from it
uh like last time i crashed bart's car
like three days ago
i wasn't on my phone where were you
where were you bart's like you did
he was asleep you can see it what were
you and i [ __ ] scraped his motorcycle
oh
on the same day
and you know what
oh good so now i can try riding your
motorcycle it won't feel bad because i
always wanted to ride a motorcycle i
never get in got into an accident that
was that was my fault
on the road all right and i've been
doing a lot of dangerous riding doing
donuts all this stuff right knock on
wood yeah but here large piece of birch
in here most of my uh fender benders and
things have been
when i'm going extremely slow and
maneuvering my car
so i was moving his truck his truck is
[ __ ] massive he drives like a semi
truck that's the leading race that has
hit you
the leading race that has hit me they
look they look like us dude probably
mexican oh insane yeah that means they
ran away too they're trying to run away
from that
one time there was an old uh mexican man
he was he was he was ahead of me and it
was at a red light and all he does is
start he backs up into me and you're
like ha ha stop and i'm like was it soft
it's hard he kind of hit me hard and i
was like i pulled over and i was like
hey man like what were you doing
like he's at first we checked for okay
he was like
yeah
he was born
in his 30s
he was in 1930 he was born but he was
like oh i was trying to get to the ralph
he's like a hundred
we're right here he pulled back this is
a couple years ago he's actually 90.
eddie he was trying to back up into me
to go to the ralphs and that's what
happened so he backed up oh so he wasn't
trying to fraud you
no he just was like oh i thought i could
do this but it's like hey man we're at a
red light yeah like there is someone
behind you there's a bunch of cars
behind you
it's a high traffic area yeah sounds
like you let him slide he and i didn't
nothing happened i didn't i didn't like
wow you're the reason you're the reason
we're getting walked all over probably
um
i let that guy let go
wow so one time um i was at a parked at
a bank and then this mexican dude
rear-ended me right and then i got out
of the car and he goes do you even have
insurance
and i'm all like come on dude that's
like the reverse
i had a similar thing where a white dude
and he's the one that hit me i was
parked i got hit by somebody at a light
they hit me on the side so my car the
back end of my car kind of like spun out
oh [ __ ] and i pulled i like drove into a
carl's jr kind of like my
i went into the parking lot but i went
over the grass and the same thing old
white man i get out of the car
this is when i had my mohawk
he's like goddamn puerto ricans and he
goes you even have insurance and i threw
my insurance card at him you're like
yeah like totally i was like whatever it
did i was like you're still using paper
i got on my phone [ __ ]
you threw your phone at him no i threw i
threw the piece of paper that i had
because i knew i had it on my phone so i
could be a tough guy
what did he do afterwards he was like oh
we have the same insurance company
that's what he said after like mildly
trying to like racially intimidate me
we're mercury bros
mercury
it's just a big ad and i was like and
that that disarmed me because he became
so gentle and nice i think he just
thought i was just like some [ __ ]
hooligan but was he was a white dude
yeah just an older white guy he came
aggressive to me first people he's like
you got insurance and i'm like
yeah i found that like older white guys
are really good at flipping after they
realize that the situation really is
dude there's this white [ __ ] come at you
really hard and then they just get cool
we were driving like this
i was i guess in her blind spot and she
and no i i was ahead because her i had a
are you about to realize it was your
fault
i was like wait no actually no we were
driving like this she merges and hits
the back end of my car and she gets out
i was like what were you doing
that's what she says to me i was like
[ __ ] you were the one emerging i was
driving straight you were trying to get
in my lane and you still hit me i was
ahead of you like how does this happen
and she was so [ __ ] rude to me
but
nothing ever happened out of that
did you change the chairs i love all
your cars did her insurance company
cover your costs uh nothing really
happened like it was like a small script
like scrape and i just buffed it out i
just buffed it out it was like that's
the mind-blowing [ __ ] is people hit you
and they go what the [ __ ] idiot and i'm
like
i was stopped yeah that's but that's all
that's all road rage stopped at a red
light i saw somebody back into a garbage
can that was bolted into the ground
and that was [ __ ] hilarious did they
get mad at the garbage can why are you
there because they thought they backed
into a car because it was in a parking
lot because we were at like griffith
this observatory
and so at the bottom parking lot like
one of the garbage cans is bolted to the
ground and i saw this dude just go
and just bang and like hit it in the
garbage can did not [ __ ] wow because
it was one of those garbage cans that
was in a
like a rock mold you know what i'm
talking about right that's like speckled
with the small part
and so like the garbage cans like inside
of it and that's also it looks like a
radioactive garbage
like it was like the oohs like they
dumped on the ninja turtles and they're
like yeah i just put this garbage can
right here
and then i started doing this guy he
rolls his window he's like what the [ __ ]
and he like turns around and look and
there's nobody in there what did he
think was gonna happen
do we have an insurance garbage can
because of the force he backed into it
like he didn't see the he didn't see the
trash can no because he was like in this
big pickup truck
so he was probably just in his blind
zone so he thought he hit like a stinky
smart car he was the autopilot
yeah that's [ __ ] funny me and my
sister were there now we couldn't stop
like bro it's literally a trash can yeah
you freaking idiot look over your
shoulder [ __ ] what's the matter with
you that's hilarious
[Music]
you